bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 7 8 lecture
le journal de la rédaction sur TVfil 78
il est 18h si vous nous rejoignez en
direct et voici les titres de ce lundi
26 mai les résultats des élections
européennes nous ferons un point sur
notre circonscription de l'Île-de-France
mais aussi sur les Yvelines première
force du département l'UMP le PS est une
nouvelle fois sévèrement battue le Front
national progresse mais moins que dans
le reste de la France toutes les
réactions à suivre à la veille du
scrutin européen les maires opposés à la
réforme des rythmes scolaires se sont
retrouvés à Paris une manifestation
devant les grilles du ministère de
l'Éducation menée conjointement avec des
parents mais aussi des enseignants et
puis en Sport le club de rugby de
plaisir face à Chartres pour décrocher
un billet en fédéral de l'année
prochaine le club yvelinois s'est imposé
le résumé est du match ce sera à la fin
de cette édition nous débutons donc avec
les résultats aux européennes et tout
d'abord les chiffres de l'abstention en
France en Île-de-France et dans les
Yvelines abstention finalement moins
élevées qu'en 2009 même si plus d'un
Français sur deux n'a pas fait le
déplacement plus de 54% des yvelinesois
sont restés chez eux Stéphane Manson
bonsoir vous êtes professeur de droit à
l'université de Versailles 50 ans on
Yvelines doyen honoraires de la Faculté
de droit et de sciences politiques votre
regard sur ces chiffres les chiffres de
l'abstention une fois de plus l'Europe
ne mobilise pas même si c'est légèrement
mieux l'Europe ne mobilise pas et j'ai
presque envie de vous dire que alors il
ne faudrait jamais dire jamais mais
qu'en principe est sauf cas
extraordinaire l'Europe ne mobilisera
jamais les élections européennes sont en
effet l'archétype même du processus
électoral considéré comme étant éloigné
des préoccupations quotidiennes alors
quand on veut taper dessus en revanche
on se mobilise un peu plus on l'a vu on
l'a vu dimanche hier en revanche il
n'est pas si vous voulez
particulièrement étonnant que ce type de
scrutin ne mobilise pas autant que les
autres alors si on regarde la courbe
depuis les premières élections les
premières élections européennes mes
élections Parlement européen on
s'aperçoit en effet que c'est plutôt
décroissant
si on regarde ce qui se passe dans les
autres États européens on s'aperçoit que
la situation française est plutôt
globalement dans la moyenne il faut
savoir que les États d'Europe centrale
et orientale
boude ces élections parfois jusqu'à
hauteur de 80% des 80% d'abstention dans
certains états donc on en est pas encore
là certes la situation n'est pas
réjouissante de ce point de vue mais en
tout cas elle n'a rien de ni en soi
d'allarment ni d'étonnant on ne vote pas
mais ce n'est pas grave ça pourrait être
pire c'est ça le message on vote un peu
mais pour autant il faut pas en déduire
que le Parlement européen n'est pas
légitime c'est un exemple que je cite
souvent à titre de comparaison le la
Chambre des représentants aux États-Unis
d'Amérique ne mobilise pas le corps
électoral à plus de 40% pour autant on
ne dit pas que la Chambre des
Représentants n'a pas de légitimité donc
à mon avis on peut appliquer cette
analyse aussi au Parlement européen il y
a plusieurs qui essaye de trouver les
causes en tout cas qui s'étape tenue
lors de ce vote européen ce sont les
moins diplômés les plus jeunes aussi
c'est ce qui ressort de ces enquêtes ça
veut dire que l'Europe que les
politiques aussi se coupent de la France
d'en bas sans être péjoratif
c'est un vaste sujet et c'est finalement
au cœur de de du résultat de ces
élections c'est ce que les collègues
chercher en sciences politiques
appellent le désenchantement de la
politique alors qu'il y a des causes
multiples et variées ou de ce que même
certains appellent
une phase post démocratique alors je
sais pas trop en quoi ça peut consister
la Poste démocratie mais en tout cas
clairement oui il y a et on le voit
encore ce soir enfin hier soir il y a
clairement une une césure une coupure
entre ce qu'on pourrait appeler les
élites et le corps des citoyens le corps
des électeurs le vote contestataire qui
s'exprime aussi par le choix du Front
national on va y venir dans un instant
mais tout d'abord micro-trottoir vous
nous expliquez pourquoi être allé voter
ce que vous en attendez il y a eu des
électeurs nous en avons rencontré c'est
au micro dès le dimanche tout simplement
pour faire mon devoir simplement voilà
ce citoyen je pense qu'il faut qu'on
participe tous donc à la vie citoyenne à
la vie collective et ça va au-delà
au-delà de notre pays donc
c'est pour ça donc pour moi il faut
qu'on aille voté également pour les
élections européennes on peut pas râler
contre l'Europe ça n'a rien décidé je
pense c'est important pour l'avenir de
la France
si on a des hommes politiques qui nous
défendent
auprès de l'Europe pour nos enfants
c'est important je suis née pratiquement
pendant la guerre et donc je sais toute
l'importance de du maintien de la paix
en Europe je crois que le les
institutions européennes peuvent y
contribuer nous parlons donc des
élections européennes ce soir dans le
journal Stéphane Manson professeur à
l'université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
va commenter ses différents résultats
avec nous ceux qui ont fait le choix du
Front national
majoritairement c'est ça s'explique
comment pourquoi ils se sont tournés
vers le Front national
il y a une chose enfin j'allais dire
assez simple qu'on peut constater c'est
la suivante c'est que au fond l'Union
européenne c'est un peu le
portrait-robot du coupable idéal pour le
Front national
progression des europhobes des
eurosceptiques se retrouvent aussi dans
d'autres pays européens alors elle se
retrouve dans certains autres pays
européens et paradoxalement d'ailleurs
pas nécessairement dans les pays les
plus ancrées
et elle se retrouve exprimée de façon
parfois assez différente
l'eurocepticisme l'europhobie c'est une
espèce de alors si j'ose dire de
sentiment assez irrationnel mais les
parties populistes ou un parti national
populiste comme le Front national surf
si j'ose dire évidemment sur cette sur
ces impressions sur ses sentiments et
engrange les succès électoraux de
manière assez large il faut le dire donc
l'Union européenne vous disait c'est
vraiment le oui c'est le portrait robot
du coupable du coupable idéal d'abord
parce que il est allé présenter cette
union européenne comme étant une espèce
de force extérieure un peu au dessus un
peu étrange composé de technocrates il y
a je le rappelle
55000 fonctionnaires à l'Union
européenne là où la ville de Paris en
emploie 52000 faire tourner lieu avec
55000 fonctionnaires ça n'est pas si mal
que cela et ça n'est pas de la
bureaucratie même s'il y a quelques
aspects à corriger donc une espèce de
force occulte extérieure qui dirigerait
les choses de surcroît ça rejoint le la
pseudo théorie la théorie électoraliste
du Front national autour de cette
entente de ce qu'ils appellent l'UMPS
c'est-à-dire une alliance
plus ou moins ouverte entre l'UMP en
France et le Parti socialiste c'est vrai
que l'Union européenne le Parlement
européenne fonctionne autour d'un
système de compromis de consensus
articulé essentiellement autour de trois
parties les conservateurs les
sociaux-démocrates et le libéraux alors
le système est tel qu'il est il a des
aspects critiques mais en tout cas rien
ne se fait au Parlement européen et dans
l'Union européenne sans ce système de
compromis
donc c'est deux seuls éléments auxquels
il faut ajouter évidemment un mode de
scrutin à la proportionnelle intégrale
qui permet de prendre une photographie
exacte de la situation du corps
électoral à un moment donné les
élections européennes donc pour le Front
national c'est un peu si j'ose dire
inscritin d'aubaine ça ne l'a pas
toujours été mais au regard du contexte
actuel et du contexte français actuel
c'est sans aucun doute inscrit un
domaine la photographie exacte du corps
électoral justement en Île-de-France la
voici voici les résultats sur notre
circonscription voyez le MP qui arrive
en tête qui récupérera quatre sièges le
Front national
17,31% trois sièges le Parti socialiste
donc qui décroche avec 14% et qui
récupérera trois sièges alors que les
centres resteront deux sièges Europe
Écologie Les Verts de siège et c'était
une lourde défaite pour Europe Écologie
au regard des résultats de 2009
puisqu'ils avaient dépassé la barre des
16% et puis le front de gauche un siège
donc le député sortant Patrick Le Garric
qui retourne au Parlement européen dans
les Yvelines également les résultats les
enseignements qui sont sensiblement les
mêmes avec le Front national autour de
17% le PS qui enregistre en revanche
plus mauvais score à peine 11,89 % des
voix moins de 12% des voix le Parti
socialiste dans les Yvelines qui subit
une fois de plus la foudre des électeurs
c'est une constante pour le Parti
socialiste ces élections européennes ça
ne le réussit pas c'est encore plus vrai
dans le département
c'est encore plus vrai dans le
département et c'est encore pire cette
année par rapport à il y a 5 ans c'est
vrai que les élections européennes n'ont
jamais vraiment réussi au Parti
socialiste mais alors là on peut dire
que c'est presque la goutte qui va faire
déborder le vase je crois que tant du
côté du Parti socialiste a fortiori
parce qu'il est aux affaires aujourd'hui
que du côté de l'UMP alors dans les
Yvelines même si les choses sont un peu
moins vrai
tous ces résultats appellent en effet
recomposition alors qui ne peut pas se
faire du jour au lendemain mais en toute
état de cause notre paysage politique
alors c'est moins vrai encore une fois
dans les Yvelines les choses sont un peu
plus adouci mais au plan national notre
paysage politique et réellement en
décomposition ça n'est pas un phénomène
récent moi il me semble que cette
poussée du Front national à plus de 18%
on la retrouve des le 21 avril 2002
n'oublions pas qu'aux dernières
élections présidentielles le Front
National est déjà la troisième force
politique sur le plan national avec plus
de 18%. ça veut dire que le Parti
socialiste qui est en place aujourd'hui
donc principalement le Parti socialiste
à trop jouer avec le feu avec le Front
national en laissant monter le Front
national en se disant ça divise la
droite et puis finalement aujourd'hui
ils ne tiennent plus le Front national
je pense pas que qu'un parti plus qu'un
autre a réellement joué avec le feu
c'est vrai qu'on a souvent accusé le PS
de
d'instrumentaliser le Front national
pour nuire à la droite parlementaire je
pense que là c'est tout ce qu'on appelle
j'aime pas ce terme là la classe
politique qui doit se remettre en cause
la classe politique parlementaire et
républicaine qui doit absolument se
remettre en cause les choses vous
disaient je pense ne sont pas du jour au
lendemain il reste que cet état de
décomposition avancée désormais appelle
à un moment ou un autre une réaction
alors une réaction dans une forme de
recomposition ne serait-ce qu'une
recomposition de la géométrie de la
structure des partis politiques
actuelles on va voir comment c'est
traduit ce vote dans votre commune quels
sont les enseignements les rapports de
force qui se sont installés dans
différentes villes du département des
Yvelines avec ce reportage le point
Catherine zulato
le FN premier parti attrape après ces
élections européennes de peu mais c'est
inscrit dans le marbre le Front national
réalise 18,60% des voix en 2009 le parti
frontiste n'avait obtenu que 4,60% des
suffrages un résultat d'autant plus
regardé la loupe que c'est dans cette
ville socialiste que siège notamment en
qualité de conseillers municipal le
ministre de l'éducation nationale Benoît
Hamon le parti de Marine Le Pen devance
de quelques voiles la liste socialiste
et la liste Front de Gauche l'UMP est le
quatrième partie à noter également que
seulement 25% des électeurs trappistes
se sont déplacés aux urnes le FN qui
arrive en seconde position à la verrière
avec
17,16% des voix derrière la liste Front
de Gauche couleur politique du maire
sortant le PS et 3e l'UMP quatrième en
2009 le Front national n'avait réalisé
que 3,49% des voix
une surprise à Magny-les-Hameaux ville
socialiste l'UMP arrive en tête avec
16,64% des voix talonnées par le PS
16,34%. par contre pas de surprise à
elle encourt ou l'UMP réalise 25,49% des
voix le maire de la commune Jean-Michel
fourgouse était 7e sur la liste d'Alain
lamasour mais le résultat du parti dans
la circonscription de l'Île-de-France ne
lui permet pas d'être élu seul 4 députés
emperont à Strasbourg les autres
communes de l'agglomération concernent
leur couleur politique à Guyancourt
c'est le parti socialiste qui arrive en
tête avec 18,40% des voix devant l'UMP
le FN et la liste udi modem à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux la ville du
divers droit de Michel Laugier l'UMP
réalise 20,77% des suffrages devant la
liste udi modem même cas de figure à
Voisins le bretonneux la commune avait
été emportée en mars dernier par l'UDI
Alexandra Rosetti le parti centriste
réalise 21,02% des suffrages devancés de
deux points par l'UMP le Front national
ne réalise plus de 12% des voix là où en
2009 il n'avait même pas atteint les
deux pourcents Voisins le bretonneux qui
remporte la palme du civisme pour
l'agglomération plus de 50% des
électeurs inscrits se sont déplacés aux
urnes autour de 50 ans on Yvelines a
noté que l'UMP confirme son ancrage à
Maurepas la ville auparavant divers
gauche avait basculé à droite aux
municipales de mars même cas de figure à
Bois-d'Arcy ou le MP fait plus de 23%
des voix contre 12% pour le PS dans ces
deux villes auparavant à gauche a noté
la forte progression du Front national
qui arrive en seconde position un FN
également sur la deuxième marche au
Clayes-sous-Bois à Saint-Cyr-l'École et
à Coignières reléguant le Parti
socialiste comme troisième formation
dans ces communes dans les Yvelines
globalement l'UMP reste majoritaire avec
24,86% des voix c'est toutefois 10
points de moins qu'aux dernières
élections européennes de 2009 le Front
National et le second parti du
département avec
17,77% des suffrages en 2009 la liste
d'Hubert dubone avait seulement totalisé
3,95%, c'est donc le grand gagnant de
ces élections du Daily modem et 3e et le
Parti socialiste quatrième avec 11,89%
des voix une consolation pour la
formation de gauche en 2009 dans les
Yvelines Harlem Désir n'avait seulement
réalisé que 11,60% des voix imperdant
dans le département europécologie les
Verts en 2009 la liste menée par Daniel
comme bénite avait totalisé
19,58% des voix 5 ans plus tard la liste
verte n'emporte que 7,64% des suffrages
le message des municipales qui est
amplifié d'une certaine manière le PS
s'effondre dans la plupart des communes
même les communes que le Parti
socialiste avait réussi à confirmer à
conserver on va revoir les résultats de
deux communes manilhéamo trappes par
exemple manileamo c'est l'UMP qui
l'emporte alors que elle sait bien le
maire socialiste qu'il avait emporté en
mars dernier même à trappe le Front
National qui cette fois-ci arrive en
tête même si la participation était très
faible est-ce que ça veut dire aussi que
les électeurs se sont trompés de scrutin
nous enfin je pense pas qu'il faille
strictement analyser les scrutins d'une
telle ampleur comme les élections
Parlement européen en comparaison avec
les élections municipales qui restent
alors même si on l'a vu il y a un mois
et demi
ces dernières élections étaient
extrêmement si j'ose dire nationalisée
mais qui reste encore des scrutins très
très locaux donc il y a assez
fréquemment des déconnexions entre les
élections municipales et les autres
scrutins cela n'a rien de
particulièrement choquant ne doit pas
susciter d'interrogations au-delà de ce
que ça mérite on va écouter la réaction
du représentant du Front national à
présent il était également présent sur
la liste en Île-de-France une formation
qui progresse vous l'avez vu être très
fortement sur le secteur sur la
circonscription sur le département des
Yvelines mais cependant cette
progression est en retrait par rapport
au reste de la France
du temps de Jean-Marie Le Pen dans les
Yvelines on avait deux points d'écart
avec avec le National à peu près ces
derniers temps on était montés à trois
ou quatre pour les municipales on avait
avoir 4 points d'écart ce qui était déjà
pas satisfaisant pour moi
mais là on est passé à 7 quoi on est
passé à 7 points d'écart par rapport
donc
au score national on est à 17 le score
national est à 24 il y a 7 mois d'écart
et là ça devient carrément inquiété
encore est-ce que c'est le discours de
Marine qui convient pas aux catégories
socioprofessionnelles des Yvelines
peut-être est-ce que c'est
est-ce que c'est
comment dire peut-être le choix de la
tête de liste j'en sais rien est-ce que
voilà ce qu'il y a eu des choses qui
n'ont pas fonctionné cette fois-ci mais
c'est clair que il faut se poser la
question on va vraiment personne au
conseil général et là il faudrait au
prochain cantonales qu'on essaie d'avoir
une percée si entre temps il y a pas de
législatives qui quand même pas
impossible à mon avis le gouvernement ne
trouvera plus sa majorité dans
l'Assemblée nationale tel quel
le Front National qui progresse même si
il progresse moins et qui entend
s'enraciner dans le département à
travers les élections des conseillers
départementaux mais aussi pourquoi pas
des législatives on en est pas encore là
comment on peut expliquer que le Front
national n'arrive pas à s'installer dans
le département autant que dans le reste
de la France il y a une explication à ça
alors d'explication immédiate je n'en
vois pas mais je constate quand même que
progressivement le Front National au
plan des sur le plan des Yvelines au
niveau des Yvelines mais il s'implante
alors pas autant pas aussi vite pas
aussi fort mais enfin il s'implante
quand même c'est à dire que la droite
résiste suffisamment parce que c'est une
un territoire de droite parce que les
candidats ceux qui se présente aussi
sont clairement identifiés il y a une
alchimie assez complexe et finalement
très globalement inexplicable si vous
voulez mais les Yvelines sont un terreau
traditionnel de la droite parlementaire
c'est sans doute pour cela je pense que
le que le Front National a un peu plus
de difficultés à progresser on va
écouter justement la réaction à présent
de Jean-Michel fourgousse pour l'UMP le
maire de long cours qui était présent
sur la liste d'Alain lamasso et pour
l'UMP l'Île-de-France est une poche
d'air dans ce scrutin
on n'est pas forcément très satisfait de
voir que c'est le Front National qui va
être le premier groupe français de
député oui c'est vrai que c'est un peu
préoccupant dans la mesure où le Front
National a peu de compréhension de
l'Europe de l'économie de la
mondialisation et de comment bien
protéger la France par les mécanismes
bon au niveau européen ça reste quand
même le même c'est le Parti populaire
européen le PPE qui va diriger l'Europe
donc là-dessus il y a rien de changer
cela dit ce n'est pas le l'UMP je vous
rappelle qu'il est au pouvoir c'est tout
de même le Parti socialiste français
donc on aimerait que Monsieur
Hollande y fasse son travail avant de
nous rendre le pouvoir donc la main
solidité vous inquiétez pas on ira et je
pense qu'on se doute un peu du résultat
mais c'est pas l'objet pensant à la
France et à réformer la France
aujourd'hui Monsieur Hollande montre un
peu le sang son sens de l'intérêt
général où tous les français
s'interrogent
l'UMP à ce niveau battu par le Front
national le PS un niveau bas historique
même si en 2009 le résultat n'était déjà
pas très très glorieux il y a des
précédents
de ce point de vue là non
alors c'est en quoi la presse
aujourd'hui par le séisme je pense qu'il
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure qu'il
s'agit plutôt d'une réplique alors d'une
réplique forte mais d'une réplique d'une
espèce de technonique des plaques c'est
à dire de déplacement des plaques
politiques les unes par rapport aux
autres qui est à l'oeuvre depuis à peu
près une bonne dizaine d'années
maintenant
alors il y a presque ce que disait
Jean-Michel fourgousse de ce point de
vue là est juste dire que il y a presque
plus de conséquences à tirer sur le plan
national que sur le plan de l'Union
européenne parce que c'est vrai que
cette très forte très forte progression
du Front National
au plan européen ne changera globalement
rien alors je dis globalement il ne faut
pas croire tout de même que cette
poussée des eurosceptiques ou des
europhobes laissera insensible les trois
gros parties de gouvernement de
européenne je crois que je suis assez
convaincu que l'Union européenne est
beaucoup plus démocratique qu'on ne veut
bien le dire et je suis aussi absolument
convaincu qu'elle n'a jamais été autant
démocratique qu'aujourd'hui de manière
assez paradoxale d'ailleurs je crois que
les électeurs français ne se sont
absolument pas rendus compte de cet
aspect là il faut dire qu'ils n'ont pas
été réellement aider par les élus les
élus nationaux jamais le Parlement
européen n'a été aussi démocratique
lorsque l'on sait que le président de la
Commission européenne doit en principe
être proposé au Parlement en tenant
compte alors il y a des interprétations
possibles mais globalement depuis le
traité de Lisbonne en tenant compte du
résultat des élections c'est la première
fois donc on peut pas encore parler de
système parlementaire au sein de l'Union
européenne mais on constate une chose
c'est que le système est beaucoup plus
démocratique et beaucoup moins
bureaucratique qu'on a bien voulu le
dire pendant longtemps pour en revenir
au niveau national est-ce que le Parti
socialiste peut se relever
nouvelle donne par exemple qui est une
formation à la marge du Parti socialiste
fondé par d'anciens socialistes déçuki
fédère 3% en Île-de-France par exemple
alors la question qui se pose pour le
Parti socialiste elle est compliquée
parce que le Parti socialiste est aux
affaires il est au pouvoir et tant qu'il
sera au pouvoir la nécessité
reconfiguration non pas seulement du
Parti socialiste mais de la gauche
française sera assez compliqué je crois
que pour qu'une reconfiguration digne de
ce nom puisse intervenir il va falloir
que le Parti socialiste sorte de la
majorité pour pouvoir j'allais dire
laver son linge sale en famille et
régler ses propres affaires mais on voit
qu'aujourd'hui même au sein du Parti
socialiste on voit bien qu'il y a
globalement deux grosses tendances qui
se dessinent elles ont toujours existé
mais elles ressortent avec beaucoup plus
de contrastes aujourd'hui entre ce qu'on
pourrait appeler les sociaux-démocrates
qui se qui assument de mieux en mieux ce
qu'ils sont et ceux qui sont plutôt
d'une gauche un peu plus traditionnelle
qui ne n'entendent pas suivre
cette cette ligne plutôt réformatrice et
sociaux-démocrate donc
de ce point de vue là la reconfiguration
à l'intérêt tant la droite parlementaire
que la gauche la réaction de la gauche à
présent avec Michel christofu livre
linoise elle était sur la liste
socialiste en Île-de-France et pour elle
déjà la montée du Front national dans le
département était prévisible
il y a déjà eu une alerte très forte qui
a été donnée avec l'élection à
Mantes-la-Ville donc d'un maire Front
national donc c'était le seul
département de l'Île-de-France ou cette
situation c'est passé donc effectivement
c'est un peu encore avec avec ce
phénomène des Yvelines ont été toujours
pour la gauche interdit mission c'est
bien connu nous avons très peu voilà
nous
avons alors des dernières législatives
nous avons aujourd'hui une seule
sédatrice donc de toute façon l'usine
sont une terre extrêmement
pour le pour la gauche en général
bon ben écoutez voilà je suppose que
nous allons nous réunir au niveau de la
Fédération bien évidemment ça n'a pas
été fait encore et puis nous allons voir
comment comment rectifier tout cela et
faire en sorte le Parti socialiste et la
gauche reprennent un peu des couleurs
dans ce département je crois qu'on a
annoncé la mort du Parti socialiste des
quantités de foi il est toujours là donc
bon il y a peut-être besoin de d'évoluer
ce n'est pas ce serait pas la première
fois qu'il aurait évolué peut-être qu'il
y a besoin d'une recomposition politique
à gauche ou à droite parce que c'est la
défaite d'hier bon elle est vraie pour
tous les parties en fait et pas
seulement le Parti socialiste
une dernière question pour conclure à
quoi doit-on s'attendre pour les
prochaines élections au même genre de
résultats la même hiérarchie politique
les prochaines élections sur les
élections régionales
et les élections régionales dont on ne
connaît pas la date encore dont on ne
connaît pas la date la loi doit sortir
dans peu de temps pour fixer justement
cette cette date mais les élections
régionales sont aussi assez
traditionnellement assez classiquement
un type de scrutin au sein duquel les
citoyens si j'osent dire se défoule
assez volontiers parce qu'il l'estime ce
scrutin d'un enjeu assez mineur donc on
risque de voir alors dans une telle
ampleur une telle proportion ça je
m'aventurerai pas le prévoir le prédire
mais en tout cas on risque en effet de
voir une confirmation à peu près
identique de l'état du rapport de force
actuelle oui merci Stéphane Manson pour
ces commentaires ces analyses sur les
résultats sur ces élections européennes
en Île-de-France dans les Yvelines et
demain mardi à partir de 18h30 et aussi
à 19 de 30 édition spéciale du 7 8
politique nous analyserons une fois de
plus les résultats vous entendrez
d'autres réactions celles et notamment
des centristes que qui sont plutôt
satisfaits des résultats obtenus lors de
ce scrutin autre sujet les élus étaient
dans la rue samedi journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
rythmes scolaires qui se tenaient à
Paris à l'appel d'un collectif de mer
mené par Lady les long courtois
Jean-Michel fourgousse les manifestants
qui veulent est dénoncer fatigue des
enfants et contre élevés de la réforme
Olivier Maniscalco et le dit moine
il faut que cette réforme soit abrogée
point final il faut que le ministre est
le courage d'abroger cette réforme une
réforme des rythmes scolaires toujours
vivement contestée samedi à Paris une
manifestation nationale réunissait tout
un cortège de mer de commune
d'enseignants et de parents tous
mécontents des parents qui dénoncent
clairement la fatigue de leurs enfants
avec une demi-journée de plus à l'école
le mercredi et qui appelle toboycott de
la prochaine rentrée scolaire qui a déjà
une mise en appel pour boycotter
carrément le jour de la rentrée c'est
bien au niveau des parents qu'au niveau
des enseignants et puis on paye contrat
tous les mercredis s'il faut moi
clairement je le sacrifierai pas mes
enfants juste pour que monsieur Peillon
et Monsieur Hamon inscrivent leur nom à
l'histoire de l'éducation nationale
voilà les enfants sont fatigués il est
pas question qu'on le sacrifie côté mer
et enseignant pointe du doigt le coup
élevé de cette réforme sont pour autant
y trouver un intérêt pédagogique certain
les parents sont irrités les profs sont
démotivés les mers sont sont asphyxiés
dynamiquement comment peut-on balancer
une telle réforme avec un tel coup sans
aucune étude d'impact scientifique ni
financière alors qu'il s'agit de
l'avenir de nos enfants je ne vois pas
ce que ça peut apporter aux enfants
dans du Midi éventuellement d'un quart
d'heure et le temps du soir d'une
demi-heure et que c'est pas dans ce
temps-là qu'on va faire des activités
intéressantes pour les enfants donc ça
nous mentir que nous dire que les
enfants vont avoir une activité sportive
ou culturelle c'est un leurre prochain
rendez-vous des anti-réformes des
rythmes scolaires le 11 juin avec une
opération école vide durant cette
journée le ministre de l'Éducation
Benoît a moins de son côté réaffirmé que
la réforme serait bien appliquée à la
rentrée prochaine le temps scolaire
n’étant pas décidé par les élus mais par
l'État
merci de nous avoir suivis l'essentiel
du sport c'est tout de suite sur TVfil
avec Anthony recherche excellente soirée